water you might not see it but this is
probably the strangest thing in the
universe here's why every molecule of
water on the earth and inside you or any
other living thing has existed for
billions of years after it came to earth
that water has been cycling through
rocks air animals plants come back again
each molecule has been on an incredible
voyage before coming to you at some
point the water inside you would have
been inside dinosaurs bacteria the
oceans storm clouds the polar ice caps
and much more all of the water on Earth
is alien they might be a familiar part
of our world but our oceans formed
hundreds of millions of years after our
planet took shape the water arrived on
asteroids and comets from space objects
from the edge of our solar system
they were leftovers of the vast clouds
of dust and rocks but didn't quite make
it into planets this is the origin of
all the water you can see leo
water doesn't follow the normal rules of
chemistry for a start it shouldn't
really be a liquid on our planet a water
molecule is made from two very light
Matson's hydrogen and oxygen and at the
temperatures and pressures on the
surface of the earth the rules of
chemistry say that water should be a gas
and unlike any other chemical when water
freezes it expands and so ice floats on
water now you see this every day but
take a moment to think about how weird
that is over time this odd behavior has
been very useful by insulating the water
underneath floating ice has enabled
complex life to survive and evolve on
our planet despite the many ice ages
that have frozen the Earth's solid and a
strangeness just goes on and on did you
know the hot water freezes faster than
cold yes really no one knows why water
molecules can float upwards against the
force of gravity that's because they
love to stick to each other they're so
good at it
that they can actually pull each other
up through tiny channels such as the
tiny blood vessels in your body that's
how oxygen and nutrients reach the edges
of your brain the same process called
capillary action allows plants to move
water from deep below the ground to
nourish the leaves and branches that
grow in the sunshine our solar system is
drowning in water once upon a time we
thought that we were alone on earth with
so much water but in fact it's the
second most common molecule in the
universe we now know there's water on
the moon on Mars Pluto in fact there's
h2o
but although
every object in our solar system and
where there's water there could be life
so pour yourself a glass of water now
and take a good look at this colorless
featureless and tasteless material it's
actually remarkable it breaks so many
rules of chemistry that scientists
struggle to understand it but without
its rebel behavior
none of us nor our world would exist
you're only here watching this video
because water is so strange
you